[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans cette édition de senna 360 voici
les titres ça suffit c'est sous ce cri
d' alerte que vont se réunir ce soir un
peu partout en france des représentants
de partis politiques une vingtaine de
ministres et tous les français qui
souhaitent dire stop à la montée des
actes antisémites particulièrement
marquée ces dernières semaines à paris
le rassemblement démarrera à 19 heures
place de la république avant cela
emmanuel macron il est président du
parlement gérard larcher et richard
ferrand seront à 18h15 au mémorial de la
shoah à paris pour exprimer leur
solidarité à la communauté juive
le chef de l'état qui rappelle que
l'antisémitisme c'est la négation de ce
qu'est la république et de ce qu'est la
france
la séance de questions d'actualité au
gouvernement que vous pourrez suivre en
intégralité dans 15 minutes sera
évidemment marqué par ces faits
plusieurs questions sont prévues sur ce
sujet de la lutte contre l'antisémitisme
avec une réponse attendue de l'exécutif
et tout au long de cette émission vous
pouvez réagir sur twitter avec le
hashtag sénat 360 pour m'accompagner cet
après midi alexandre tous arrêt dans les
tribunes de l'hémicycle et à mme tran
huy en salle des conférences du sénat
le multiplex c'est tout de suite
cette journée est donc marquée par les
rassemblements contre l'antisémitisme
alors qu'un nouvel acte de profanation
d'un cimetière juif à quatzenheim en
alsace a été découvert emmanuel macron a
tenu à se rendre sur place où près d'une
centaine de tombes ont été vandalisées
le chef de l'état qui promet une réponse
ferme on les écoute prendre à des actes
on prendra des lois non punira à la fin
c'est dans la conscience de chacune et
chacun de la république
elle s'apprend elle se porte ceux qui
ont fait ça ne sont pas dignes de la
république elle les punira mais je ne
veux pas que ce qui s'est passé là donne
des idées à d'autres
et c'est aussi par la réaction de
populaire la force qu'il ya en chacun
qu'on apportera la meilleure réponse et
au sénat condamnation unanime sur tous
les bancs face à cette montée de
l'antisémitisme
de nombreux parlementaires seront
présents ce soir dans les rassemblements
mais sur les réponses à apporter
il y a parfois des divergences les
réactions au micro de celle ci dessous
et les ados plaît des croix gammées sur
le visage de simone veil alain
finkielkraut agressé en plein paris et
la profanation d'un cimetière juif
cette nuit à quatzenheim ce matin au
sénat sénateurs de droite et de gauche
sont d'accord
la multiplication des actes antisémites
ils en ont ras-le-bol via un moment
c'est stop c'est stop à cette situation
fractionnel dangereuse qui ramène de
mauvais esprit ça suffit ces actes ne
peuvent ou ne sont plus tolérables plus
en 2019 plus dans nos pays
tous les sénateurs rencontré iront ce
soir à la manifestation un acte utile
pour marquer symboliquement leur
ras-le-bol
personne ne pense qu'un tel
rassemblement va faire tomber
l'antisémitisme mécaniquement mais
l'absence de rassemblement à l'absence
de réaction le fera contestable en
montée donc c'est un premier temps un
premier temps car pour les sénateurs de
droite comme de gauche
il faut aller plus loin il ya des
mesures immédiates et des mesures de
fond
sur les mesures de fond non dur et je
pense que le travail en profondeur dès
le plus jeune âge dans l'éducation
nationale nos sites tout ce qui est
autour les asociaux et c'est sur un
comment démonter des préjugés et c'est
ensemble est une bonne chose si on veut
lutter efficacement contre
l'antisémitisme
il faut dénoncer ce lien insidieux qui
existe entre la montée des actes
antisémites et un islamisme radical
on ne pourra pas lutter contre ce
phénomène nouveau
si on le cache il faut regarder les
choses en face
une grande partie de la classe politique
sera présente au rassemblement de ce
soir au total une soixantaine de
manifestations seront organisées en
france et on prend la direction de la
salle des conférences du sénat pour une
première réaction au micro tom tran huy
tam vous êtes au côté d'esther benbassa
sénatrice écologiste de paris
oui esther benbassa tout d'abord votre
réaction à la profanation du cimetière
juif de quatzenheim dans le bas-rhin 96
tombes ont été profanées
je trouve que c'est vraiment très
regrettable vous savez que l'alsace a
été un haut lieu
n'est ce pas d'implantations juives et
même après las l'expulsion des juifs au
moyen âge de du royaume de france
historienne qui parle et c'est vraiment
je suis très attristé et qu'on en arrive
là et en même temps on voit combien
l'antisémitisme et multiforme ceux qui
veulent réduire sa seulement gilet jaune
seulement à l'extrême droite seulement à
l'extrême gauche
eh bien on aussi à prendre en
considération ce fléau qui a est était
déjà présent vous savez que ce n'est pas
nouveau mais là il y à une résurgence
parce que dès qu'il y à crise économique
puis sociale crise identitaire et on le
prend comme cible est minoritaire
vous voyez la montée de nouveau
président le racisme de l'antisémitisme
voilà toutes ces discriminations qui
monte c'est lié aussi ce n'est pas ce
n'est pas pour cela qu'il faut pardonner
aux comprend il n'ya rien à comprendre
il faut un travail d'éducation continue
un travail d'explication ne pas
instrumentaliser l'antisémitisme de
quelques t que ça soit 6 mai que c'est
le cas aujourd'hui on a vu qu'il y avait
des polémiques par rapport à la
manifestation de ce soir certains qui
pointe du doigt bien le rassemblement
national mais aussi la france un soumise
par exemple écouter l'affluence
insoumise lors de la manifestation pour
madame la défunte madame knoll n'est ce
pas
les gilles la france insoumise a été
délogé de la manifestation par une ligue
juive qui est quand même assez radical
peut-être que ça ça ça a quand même un
peu touché les membres de la france
insoumise mais aujourd'hui il faut pas
qu'il joue sur les mots
aujourd'hui symboliquement il faut être
là où il faut il faut être ce soir à la
république parce que nous devons même si
c'est symboliquement c'est pas que nous
allons arrêter nous même l'antisémitisme
mais il faut être là pour montrer
connaît connaît tous ensemble contre
d'antisémitisme j'ai même appelé les
gilet jaune et je les ai appelés à
condamner l'antisémitisme
il y a déjà deux fly ryder et jérôme
gingembre et rodrigues qui ont répondu
avec un cp qui condamne l'antisémitisme
merci beaucoup esther benbassa pour
votre réaction
merci thème faut-il pénalisé
l'antisionisme pour lutter contre
l'antisémitisme l'initiative de députés
fait débat pour eux la contestation de
l'état d'israël nourrit l'antisémitisme
mais beaucoup des bus s'inquiète d'un
délit d'opinion et au sénat louis du
mesnil est allé voir ce qu'en pensent
les sénateurs des propos qui soulève
l'ambiguïté anti sioniste ou antisémite
pour le député sylvain maillard la
réponse est toute trouvée
l'antisionisme et le visage masqué de
l'antisémitisme au 21ème siècle
très clairement on a eu d'ailleurs un
exemple samedi dernier où
alain finkielkraut se fait attaquer par
un gilet jaune qui lui dit sale sioniste
de merde qu'est ce qui veut dire sale
juif de merde mais en utilisant le
vocable sioniste il sait très bien qui
sera probablement pas poursuivi le
représentant de la république en marche
va même plus loin il souhaite la
reconnaissance officielle de l'anti
sionisme comme antisémitisme l'objectif
une proposition de loi ou moins
contraignants une résolution pour faire
de l'anti sionisme un délit mais au
sommet de l'état on ne partage pas cet
avis je confirme que ceux qui
aujourd'hui dans le discours veulent la
disparition d'israël sont ceux qui
veulent s'attaquer aux juifs je pense
néanmoins que lorsqu'on rentre dans le
détail la condamnation pénale de
l'antisionisme pose d'autres problèmes
emmanuel macron qui parlait pourtant de
l'anti sionisme comme une forme
réinventer de l'antisémitisme en 2017
les définitions sont néanmoins
distinctes l'antisémitisme renvoie à la
haine et à la discrimination à
l'encontre des juifs est répréhensible
par la loi
l'antisionisme renvoie à l'hostilité à
l'encontre de l'état d'israël mais n'est
pas puni par la loi
un tour de passe-passe linguistique à
régulariser pour certains pour d'autres
légiférer s'avère plus périlleux
moi je ne soutiens absolument pas ce que
fait le gouvernement israélien et
notamment vis-à-vis des palestiniens
toutes les colonies qui se développent
et si on ne peut plus critiqué le
gouvernement israélien sent tout de
suite être taxé de propos antisémites là
c'est très grave c'est une atteinte aux
libertés un débat récurrent et qui
revient à l'heure où les actes
antisémites ont augmenté de 74 % en un
an et on retourne en salle des
conférences du sénat ou dang tran huy
vous êtes avec le sénateur les
républicains du rhône françois noël
buffet oui françois noël buffet d'abord
votre réaction à la profanation du
cimetière juif de quatzenheim alors que
tout à l'heure et bien le président de
la république a déclaré on prendra des
lois on punira qu'est ce que vous
attendez de la part du gouvernement
tout d'abord c'est d'abord une
condamnation ferme de ce nouvel
événement c'est insupportable il faut le
dire et j'espère que ce soit puisque un
rassemblement important à paris et dans
toute la france il conviendra que les
français se mobilisent
on ne peut pas tolérer une seule seconde
de plus ce qui se passe après sur la
façon de fonctionner l'arsenal juridique
existe les lois pénales existe le droit
pénal prévoit des sanctions il faut
évidemment que les poursuites engagées
et les condamnations prononcées doivent
être fermes
si on veut aggravé les choses une fois
son la modifier le quantum des peines à
la peine encourue la faire évoluer et
sanctionner de manière plus forte tout
ce qui constitue des actes racistes
d'une façon générale de manière à ce que
peut on soit très très ferme
il ne faut pas laisser une seule un seul
espace de doute dans nos choix
ce matin le président de la république a
semblé repoussé la proposition de loi de
sylvain maillard qui assimile
antisionisme et antisémitisme est ce que
vous jugez vous qu'il aurait fallu cette
proposition g je pense que non en
réalité parce qu'il faut un texte qui
reste caractère général et qui
s'applique à l'ensemble situation je
suis beaucoup plus favorable à ce que
effectivement on revoit la peine
encourue et qu'on aggrave la peine
encourue pour ses comportements et ses
actes cela je pense que ça aurait du
sens
et que serait de l'utilité on attend
également et bien demain à la remise du
rapport de la commission denquête
benalla ça va être le temps fort de
cette semaine au sénat
quelles sont vos conclusions
personnelles sur ce rapport puisque je
le précise vous n'êtes pas rapporteur
non mes conclusions personnelles
c'est d'abord il y avait un parjure tout
au long de cette édition et que je
souhaite en tout cas j'espère que la
commission saisit râle procure un pays
de cette affaire là ensuite c'est le
constat sur le fond que jamais cette
affaire n'aurait dû avoir lieu si
monsieur benalla très vite avait été
sous contrôle et qu'on les stopper
rapidement et je pense que
malheureusement il a pris beaucoup trop
de pouvoir beaucoup trop d'importance
et on l'a laissé faire la question qui
se pose réellement c'est pourquoi
l'at-on laisser faire ça c'est vraiment
la question de fond pourquoi
et puis enfin quel dispositif doit être
mis en place maintenant pour protéger
encore plus l'institution
le président de la république
tout est bien sûr que d'édition bien sûr
il ya eu des dysfonctionnements cascade
il faut les corriger les corriger
rapidement pour que effectivement
l'institution de l'elysée le président
la réplique soit dans une situation de
certitudes et pas de voir des études des
situations comme celle-ci où une
personne parce qu'elle décide de prendre
le pouvoir on le laisse faire
arrive finalement à créer des
difficultés très importantes jugé que la
gestion de l'exécutif n'a pas été à la
hauteur en tout cas ça c'est certain
je la trouve plutôt en dessous de tout
eh bien merci beaucoup aux français la
ville fait d'avoir répondu à un making
of heroes merci tam et françois noël
buffet vient de l'évoquer c'est demain
matin que la commission d' enquête
sénatoriale sur la sphère benalla
présente son rapport tant attendu après
six mois d'enquêté d'audition avant cet
épilogue
retour sur les points clés de la faire
signer quand un calme et c'est officiel
mercredi les sénateurs rendront enfin
leurs conclusions dans la tentaculaire
affaire banale un point de départ pour
la commission denquête les violences de
la place de la contrescarpe le monde
révèle le 18 juillet l'identité
d'alexandre benalla s'ensuivront 29
auditions dont celle de l'ancien chargé
de mission avec un constat qui apparaît
au fil des témoignages
alexandre benalla a désorganisé les
services de l'état en ce qui concerne
monsieur ben alla je ne suis toujours
pas convaincu qu'il n'exerçait pas la
fonction de garde du corps
comment expliquer autrement le port
d'armes
mais en décembre la sphère est relancée
lors d'une visite des manuels maquereau
au tchad
on apprend qu alexandre benalla à
continuer à utiliser des passeports
diplomatiques alors qu'il n'était plus
salariée de l'elysée les sénateurs
décide alors d'organiser cinq nouvelles
auditions
quand il va voir le prés le frère du
président du tchad qui a un rôle éminent
matière de sécurité et d'importation
d'armes au tchad et qu'il le fait avec
un passeport officiel on peut quand même
s'interroger sur le rôle réel de metz et
benhaddad dans une diplomatie parallèle
aux soupçons de diplomatie parallèle
s'ajoutent ensuite le volet sur les
contrats russe il aurait été négocié
pour l'un d'entre eux au moins alors
qu'à l'action au pénal a était encore
salarié de l'elysée je voulais vous
demander si vous connaissiez monsieur
iskander makhmoudov
je ne connais pas cette personne il a
part à travers la presse je ne les ai
jamais rencontrés
une réponse prononcée alors qu'alexandre
benalla était sous serment
de nombreux sénateurs le suspecte alors
d'avoir commis un parjure
il nous a menti en tout cas la
commission en décidera mais
manifestement il nous a menti et
sûrement pas qu'une seule fois donc on
va prospecter en la matière si nous
sommes intimement convaincus qu'il ya eu
mensonge cas ça c'est mon intime
conviction personnelle
nous devons demander à la justice de
sanctionner mme chibane a surtout ses
volets de la sphère benalla les
conclusions les sénateurs sont donc très
attendues les questions d'actualité au
gouvernement vont démarrer avant de
pouvoir les suivre en intégralité sur
notre antenne ont rejoint alexandre
poussard dans l'hémicycle pour le
sommaire des questions d'aujourd'hui
oui j'ai remis les questions d'actualité
marquer évidemment par la violence
antisémite qui sévit en ce moment en
france avec deux questions une question
de bruno retailleau le président du
groupe l'est républicain au sénat une
question de la centriste catherine morin
desailly la présidente de la commission
de la culture sur ce sujet sur cette
montée de l'antisémitisme
car aussi nous sommes à quelques heures
du rassemblement contre l'antisémitisme
ce soir dans toute la france et
notamment place de la république à paris
où se représente de nombreux partis
politiques et de nombreux parlementaires
l'ordre du jour du sénat a été gelé ce
soir pour permettre aux sénateurs
d'assister à ce rassemblement
le la cloche vient de sonner c'est le
début des questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
notre séance et retour suisse sur public
sénat et sur notre site internet au nom
du bureau une fois encore je rappelle à
chacun les principes qui sont les usages
dans cette maison le respect des uns et
les autres et le respect de son temps
qui ne peut pas être une attention qui
doit être une réalité et donc je donne
immédiatement la parole à madame la
présidente catherine morin desailly pour
le groupe de l'union centriste
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre mais très chers
collègues l'actualité là ce sont des
actes d'une ignominie tels qu'ils
remettent en cause la nature même de
notre pacte républicain
c'est le lâche assassinat de mireille
knoll la mémoire d'ilan halimi de simone
veil outrageusement bafouée l'agression
d'alain finkielkraut la profanation d'un
cimetière juif aujourd'hui même en
alsace que nous découvrons avec horreur
parfois sous couvert d'antisionisme les
comportements les plus abjects sont
permis mais gardons-nous monsieur le
premier ministre de la tentation d'un
nouveau texte de loi élaborée dans
l'émotion notre arsenal législatif ne
nous permet-il pas déjà de répondre avec
la plus grande des fermetés maintenant
l'augmentation des actes antisémites de
74 % en un an doivent nous faire réagir
ils engagent notre responsabilité
collective analyser les maux dont
souffre notre société de plus en plus
fragmenté
de plus en plus vulnérables à la
manipulation de l'information et des
faits historiques et à la propagation
d'idéologie haineuse à l'opposé de nos
valeurs républicaines
il est à cet égard nécessaire de réguler
l'internet et les plates formes qui
permettent tous les débordements
le propos de senna des propositions très
forte à cet égard mais il ya aussi
surtout à ne pas laisser s'installer
l'idée que l'antisémitisme serait une
opinion comme une autre cela passe
d'abord monsieur le premier ministre par
des précisions qui doivent être
apportées à la lettre adressée par le
monsieur le ministre de l'éducation
nationale du 31 août 2010 8 aux
enseignants et où il est question du
respect d'autrui
de la transmission des savoirs
fondamentaux et de l'éducation valeur de
la rép
blick le sénat examinera prochainement
le projet de loi relative à l'école de
la confiance c'est un véhicule idéal
permettant aussi de rappeler
l'importance et la réalité des faits
historiques ainsi que d'une éducation
aux médias et au numérique encore
largement insuffisantes
aujourd'hui tous nous oblige un
véritable sursaut républicain
mes chers collègues il y a à la pelle
des formations politiques bien sûr le
grand rassemblement à paris et dans la
france entière de ce soir qui est très
important mais au delà monsieur le
premier ministre
quelles mesures vont être prises pour
reconstruire ensemble de toute urgence
le pacte républicain auquel nous sommes
profondément attachés
je vous remercie de votre réponse pour
vous répondre à la parole monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
madame la sénatrice morin desailly vous
avez commencé votre question en
rappelant une série de faits d'actes ou
de propos antisémites
c'est fait nous les connaissons certains
ont été rendues visibles parce qu'ils
étaient filmés d'autres sont
malheureusement quotidien est invisible
ils n'en sont pas moins répugnant grave
très profondément dirigée contre ce que
nous sommes
la république ce que nous sommes la
france vous avez indiqué que nous
devions dénoncé vous avez rappelé la
marche qui sera ou plus exactement le
rassemblement qui sera organisée ce soir
à paris et dans de très nombreuses
villes françaises
ces rassemblements sont nécessaires ils
sont utiles pour que nous puissions tous
ensemble sans exclusive dire que ces
faits sont inacceptables
ils ne sont pas suffisants et nous en
avons parfaitement conscience
il faut donc face à ces atteintes
répétées répété est croissante
madame la sénatrice vous le savez
puisque les actes et les agressions
antisémites ont très fortement progressé
au cours de l'année dernière nous ne
nous ne devons pas nous contenter d'une
dénonciation moral
nous devons la faire mais nous ne devons
pas nous en contenter et évidemment le
champ de l'action est considérable c'est
d'abord et avant tout l'éducation et le
soutien aux enseignants quand il le
transmettent l'histoire les faits quand
ils sont confrontés à des propos ou à
des actes antisémites
c'est la formation des policiers des
gendarmes des magistrats qui concourent
à réprimer ou à prévenir ces atteintes
cette aussi renforcer le droit lorsque
c'est nécessaire et vous avez madame la
sénatrice indiqué qu' il ne fallait pas
légiférer sous l' empire de l'émotion je
vous rejoins volontiers sur ce sujet
mais il ne faut pas non plus renoncé à
légiférer lorsque c'est nécessaire
il y a eu au moins un champ peut être
d'autres mais au moins un champ où s'est
parfaitement nécessaire c'est celui des
réseaux sociaux et d'internet dans
lequel une forme d'impunité a pu donner
le sentiment de se développer le champ
des réseaux sociaux ou derrière une
forme d'anonymat
les femmes et des hommes écrivent
promeuvent des propos parfaitement
antisémite est parfaitement inacceptable
cette impunité ne peut pas prévaloir et
nous savons que le droit national
le veilleur à bien des égards le droit
communautaire n'est à ce jour pas adapté
à la sévérité de la réponse que nous
sommes en droit d'attendre c'est la
raison pour laquelle à la suite d'un
rapport qui a été préparée notamment par
madame la députée avia nous voulons
compléter notre droit national et
militer pour compléter le droit
communautaire de fer afin de afin de
modifier le statut de ceux qui jouent
r des réseaux sociaux et de pouvoir
aller chercher leurs responsabilités
s'ils ne font pas ce qui est nécessaire
pour retirer les publications sur ces
réseaux sociaux voir s'il ne préviennent
pas de façon efficace la commission de
tels actes qui sont je le rappelle des
délits il faudra que nous changions le
droit national et il faudra que nous
obtenions de nos partenaires européens
que nous complétions le droit
communautaire
ça vaut la peine je crois profondément
madame la sénatrice que nous devons
légiférer en la matière car il ne serait
pas acceptable qu'en matière
d'antisémitisme nous donnions le
sentiment que l'impunité pourrait
prévaloir c'est vrai aussi s'agissant de
la sévérité des sanctions qui sont
prises administrative lorsque c'est le
cas judiciaire lorsque c'est le cas
j'incite je ne peux pas à dire le terme
incité pardon je souhaite que
systématiquement les affaires dans ce
titre sémitisme donne lieu à des
poursuites je souhaite que
systématiquement elle donne lieu à des
sanctions sévères
nous devons en la matière mesdames et
messieurs les censeurs et je le dis je
le dis ah je le sais des femmes et des
hommes qui en sont convaincus nous
devons en la matière faire l'union
sacrée sans exclusive sans hypocrisie
sans incohérence l'union sacrée pour
dénoncer ces faits inacceptables
merci monsieur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
loc
parler notre collègue michel amiel pour
le groupe de la république en marche la
parole monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues
voilà quelle approche des échéances
électorales l'arlésienne c'est le cas de
le dire qui la métropole aix marseille
provence refait son apparition dans tous
les esprits
il est question le rapport du préfet de
rencontres diverses bref chacun y va de
la sienne pour être synthétique sans
être réducteur le problème peut se
résumer en quelques grands chapitres
point la fusion faute d'un mot mais hier
entre métropole et départements en se
souvenant aussi que le social constitue
la plus grande partie du budget de
fonctionnement et qu'il s'agit là d'une
culture tout à fait à part point de la
question des 29 communes du nord du
département dont certaines sont
regroupés autour d'un projet commun qui
se voudrait expérimental je parle d'une
création de collectivité territoriale à
statut particulier le point 3 le destin
de deux communes hors département des
bouches du rhône saint zacharie dans le
var et surtout pertuis dans leur auto
vers son département d'origine
le vaucluse ne fait pas l'unanimité et
il est vrai que capitale du nord luberon
père tué davantage tournée vers aix y
compris par son hôpital que vers avignon
points 4 la date est le mode de scrutin
sujet éminemment complexe et politiques
points dont cinq enfants surtout la
question budgétaire en rappelant que
marseille est une ville pauvre et que
certes s'il faut l'aider ce n'est pas en
appauvrissant les autres communes dont
les budgets sont déjà très fragile en
touchant en particulier à leur
attribution de compensation que nous
parviendrons à donner à marseille son
statut de capitale de métropole alors
madame la ministre
quand verrons-nous plus clair sur chacun
de ces points on vous répondre la parole
la ministre de la cohésion des
territoires des relations étaient
collectivités territoriales en gros vous
avez la parole madame la ministre
monsieur le président merci mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur amiel merci pour votre question
nous avons beaucoup déjà parlé de la
métropole aix marseille et bien sûr ma
conviction c'est que la métropole d'aix
marseille est une réalité bien
évidemment mais que également la ville
de marseille a besoin de se renforcer
reconnaissons le par ailleurs aix
marseille est une réalité géographique
et économique qui couvre la quasi
intégralité du département des bouches
du rhône la métropole
je crois est une chance pour les
territoires et non pas une menace
elle est le moteur d'une alliance des
territoires elle est une chance aussi
pour la ville de marseille
le premier ministre a chargé le préfet
de région préfet des bouches du rhône
monsieur pierre dartout de mener une
concertation afin d'étudier
l'opportunité les conditions et les
modalités d'une fusion entre l'actuel
métropole et le département des bouches
du rhône ce rapport sera rendu très
prochainement et il éclairera le
gouvernement sur les points que vous
avez soulevé le périmètre de la
métropole
la bonne répartition des compétences
entre la métropole et les communes ainsi
que les moyens financiers bien sûr et
bien sûr les questions électorales et je
n'oublie pas les territoires que vous
avez cités au nord de la métropole
autant de questions importantes parce
que l'enjeu est de taille
permettre à marseille cette très grande
ville française à cette métropole
méditerranéenne de répondre aux défis du
présent et de l'avenir pour tous les
citoyens des bouches du rhône
curiel quelques secondes merci madame la
ministre ne ses réponses mais faut-il
rappeler tout de même que marseille dont
vous avez cité les difficultés
financières ne pourra se rendre floues
et sans l'aide de l'état
comme ce fut d'ailleurs promis par un
ancien premier ministre mais c'est vrai
que c'était dans l'autre monde
merci la parole et à notre collègue me
réjouis pour le groupe du rassemblement
démocratique et social européen
vous avez la parole un seul président
mesdames et messieurs les membres du
gouvernement mes chers collègues nous à
la question s'adresse à monsieur le
premier ministre monsieur le premier
ministre la démocratie représentative
devant le discours ambiant nous ne
pouvons masquer notre inquiétude pour
celle que pierre rosanvallon qualifie de
seul horizon reconnu du bien politique
si certaines musiques comme la réduction
du nombre de parlementaires ou d'élus
locaux sont agréables à l'oreille de
beaucoup de nos compatriotes
elles peuvent également se révéler
pernicieuse le 14 février dernier
marquer le cinquième anniversaire de la
promulgation de la loi interdisant le
cumul de fonctions exécutives locales
avec un mandat de député ou de sénateur
au sein du gouvernement et de la
majorité avec le recul on s'interroge le
débat démocratique souffrirait-il
désormais d'une forme de déconnexion de
la représentation nationale
en effet ce qui était volontiers
présenté comme un privilège était aussi
souvent le garant d'une politique ancrée
dans la proximité et ce jusqu'au
parlement
mais on estimé qu'une mesure aussi
populaire devait être prise pour oeuvrer
à la réconciliation des français et de
leurs représentants nationaux
effectivement quelle réconciliation
monsieur le premier ministre pourquoi
continuer de courir derrière un lièvre
qui est de toute façon par nature
irrattrapable pourquoi prendre le risque
d'affaiblir encore une fois l'ancrage de
notre démocratie représentative
peut-être vos successeurs
s'interrogeront dans 5 ou 10 ans à leur
tour sur une réduction du nombre de
parlementaires et d'élus locaux
intervenus
sous cette législature quand les députés
seront devenus invisibles au sein de
circonscription de deux cent mille
habitants
quand près de la moitié de nos
départements ne comptera plus qu'un
sénateur
et quid d'une régionalisation de nos
circonscriptions qui conduirait un
sénateur a sillonné un territoire allant
d'aurillac à annecy ou de bayonne à
poitiers comme le souhaitent certains
députés de la majorité
pourquoi le maire demeure utile le
dernier élu a trouvé encore grâce aux
yeux des français
assurément par sa proximité j'aurais
envie de dire par sa réalité physique
monsieur le premier ministre alors que
vous entendez faire évoluer nos
institutions
saurez vous conduire votre réforme tout
en gardant à l'esprit que ce qui fait la
légitimité du politique passe aussi par
sa disponibilité sa disponibilité pour
les coûte le dialogue le débat auprès de
nos concitoyens sur ce point pour le
moins cruciale des jeux griveaux gentil
avec moi vous avez la parole
merci merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
madame madame la sénatrice vous citez
dans votre interpellation une belle
formule de pierre rosanvallon qui pose
la démocratie représentative comme le
seul horizon comme reconnu du bien
politique cela nous le partageons le
partageons sûr c'est bon je crois au
delà des sensibilités
je sais que vous êtes particulièrement
attachés à la démocratie représentative
et chacun des membres du gouvernement a
eu l'occasion de le rappeler dans les
semaines y compris qui se sont écoulées
où on a beaucoup parlé démocratie
directe mais où chacun a eu l'occasion
de rappeler l'importance la démocratie
représentative et de l'élection je
partage aussi ce que ce même pierre
rosanvallon écrivait dès 2006 il y à 13
ans dans la contre démocratie et ce
qu'il a appelé la politique à l'âge de
la défiance
c'était vous en conviendrez avant la loi
de 2015 que d'abord les premières
prémices de ce délitement du lien entre
nos concitoyens et leur classe politique
a marqué ses premiers éléments je vous
rejoins également madame sur un autre
point que vous mentionnez dans votre
question
la seule question du nombre de
parlementaires ne suffit pas à épuiser
celle de la vitalité de notre démocratie
de la vitalité de notre démocratie
parlementaire et de nos institutions
cet exode elle ne règle pas la question
du lien et de la distension de ce lien
entre nos élus et nos concitoyens mais
mais
pour renouer avec nos concitoyens madame
la sénatrice je le crois qu'il faut
aussi être fidèles à nos engagements de
campagne
la totalité des projets qui ont été
présentés aux français par les candidats
à l'élection présidentielle prévoyait la
baisse du nombre de parlementaires
cette fidélité aussi à des engagements
de campagne je crois est observé et en
particulier et nous le voyons dans le
grand débat national qui est organisé
depuis maintenant un mois et bien la
question de la place de notre démocratie
parlementaire est posée et je crois
qu'on peut se réjouir collectivement que
nos concitoyens s'y rendent nombreux
merci la parole est à notre collègue
pascal salvodelli pour le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen et
écologistes avaient la parole merci
monsieur le président ne parlait pas
d'acquis sociaux par les deux ponts qui
sociaux parce que le patronat de
désarment jamais c'est ambroise croizat
à monsieur le premier ministre
ambroise croizat et j'ai appris monsieur
le premier ministre que lors d'un débat
dans le finistère vous remettiez en
cause une fois encore le principe de la
solidarité nationale
alors quels sont les droits qui selon
vous devrait être soumis à contrepartie
les bénéficiaires de l'allocation adulte
handicapé devrait-il l'a mérité pour
l'obtenir
quant aux personnes sans emploi
dispose-t-elle d'une dette envers la
communauté les indemnités qu'elles
perçoivent sont un droit qu'elles ont
gagné par leur travail et par leurs
cotisations monsieur le premier ministre
et bah cette stigmatisation des
personnes les plus fragiles les plus
pauvres monsieur le premier ministre est
devenu proprement insupportable cessé de
les culpabiliser c'est votre politique
qui les exclut vous brive et d'ouvriers
des rêves mais les corps aussi et vous
distillez de l'humiliation au lieu d'
insuffler de l'espoir
pour vous répondre la parole et à madame
agnès buzyn milices des solidarités de
la santé même la ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur savoldelli vous le savez le
principe du grand débat national et de
poser des questions de réfléchir
ensemble pour le modèle que nous voulons
construire pour l'avenir et dans ce
cadre le premier ministre a posé une
question que chacun peut se poser et qui
fait d'ores et déjà partie des questions
qui sont posées aux français dans le
cadre du débat national dans la partie
démocratie et citoyenneté
la question est posée c'est faut-il des
contreparties aux allocations de
solidarité en réalité elles existent
déjà les droits et devoirs font déjà
partie de l'allocation du rsa notamment
puisque c'est une contractualisation
pour se réinsérer dans l'emploi lorsque
l'on touche le rsa il a contrepartie
elle est inscrite avec le rsa alors tout
le monde aujourd'hui connaît la
situation de deux aides sociales elles
sont très nombreuses
elles sont fragmentés elles ont été
construites par sédimentation nos
concitoyens ont du mal à s'y retrouver
nous avons décidé de simplifier l'accès
aux aides sociales notamment pour
réduire le non recours et cette
simplification c'est le revenu universel
d'activité sur lequel nous travaillons
et qui permettra je pense de de
simplifier l'accès aux aides sociales et
éviter les 30 % de bénéficiaires
aujourd'hui qui n'accède pas au rsa
nous savons aussi que nous aide sociale
ce sont des trappes à pauvreté
nous savons aussi que aujourd'hui 50 %
des allocataires du rsa ne se voient pas
proposer un parcours de réinsertion et
une contractualisation alors qu'il
touche cette allocation
il est donc nécessaire de poser cette
question droits et devoirs cela fait
partie intégrante aujourd'hui du récent
et c'est la question qui est posée dans
le cadre du grand débat né hors de
question de revenir sur l'accompagnement
de nos concitoyens le plus en difficulté
mais l'accompagnement et globale il est
financier il est celui aussi de
l'insertion de l'insertion vers l'emploi
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le premier ministre pour
sa réponse est la vôtre madame la
ministre
laissez moi vous rappeler quand même
l'article 11 du préambule de la
constitution de 46 puisqu'on va être nos
révisions constitutionnelles
je cite la nation garantit à tous sans
condition palam la ministre la
protection de la santé la sécurité
matérielle le repos et les loisirs tout
être humain qui ont raison de son âge de
son état physique ou mental de la
situation économique se trouve dans
l'incapacité de travailler a le droit
d'obtenir de la collectivité des moyens
convenables d'existence
à défaut de respecter l'héritage de la
résistance il conviendrait au moins de
respecter celui de la constitution et
puisque ces bananes busin qui me répond
j c'est quoi votre truc fragmenté
segmenter les allocations parler du rsa
le problème c'est quoi ces les
allocations familiales
tu vas falloir se doter de les payer
c'est la prestation d'accueil du jeune
enfant la prime de naissance
l'allocation chômage allocations adultes
handicapés l'allocation de complément de
libre choix d'activité pourquoi pas
demain les bourses universitaires où on
va avec ça donc franchement c'est pas
sérieux et monsieur le premier ministre
et madame la ministre j'aime fendre la
poche je vais vous offrir un livre à la
sortie de notre hémicycle ça un livre
d'edouard louis le titre c'est qui a tué
mon père vous allez désormais les droits
d'auteur ou les dominant le plus souvent
la politique est une question esthétique
une manière de penser une manière de
voir le monde tout seul son ministre en
sortant pour nous c'était vivre ou
mourir monsieur le président
[Applaudissements]
la parole les cas notre collègue sophie
taillé et poli ans pour le groupe
socialiste et républicain
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
parce que j'avais cru comprendre en
lisant ses déclarations sur les fameuses
contrepartie que c'était une opinion
personnelle est un souhait personnel
mais je vois comme la réponse de madame
la ministre à mon collègue pascal
salvodelli vient d'être fait que non il
s'agit bien d'une orientation de la
politique du gouvernement est évidemment
on peut se poser la question de se
demander mais comment peut-on demander
des contreparties à des femmes et des
hommes que l'on aide à survivre et qui
sont avant tout des victimes de notre
système économique mondial qui produit
on le sait des économies insupportable
ce qui a été tout le temps
cette petite musique de lier être social
et chômage problèmes de recrutement des
entreprises ensuite c'est à dire on
entretient une confusion volontaire pour
sous-entendre que s'il ya des chômeurs
c'est parce qu'ils ne veulent pas
traverser la rue même chiffré à 300
milles les offres d'emploi non pourvues
ne sont qu'une goutte d'eau face au
chômage de masse qui concerne 5,6
millions de personnes
oui cette question est une véritable
question sur les fondements de notre
système de sécurité sociale car la
sécurité sociale telle qu'elle a été
fondée par les ordonnances de 45 disait
à débarrasser les travailleurs de cette
incertitude constante qui crée chez eux
un sentiment d'infériorité et qui est la
base réelle et profonde disent les
ordonnances de 45 de la distinction des
classes entre les possédants sûrs
d'eux-mêmes et de leur avenir et les
travailleurs sur qui pèse à tout moment
la menace de la misère alors mass ma
question est la suivante les possédants
sûrs d'eux-mêmes et de leur avenir quand
on leur a demandé de ne plus payer les
sf on leur a demandé des contreparties
madame agnès buzyn munissent de
solidarité de la santé
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice taille à pau lyon
d'abord nous ne parlons pas ici de la
sécurité sociale la sécurité sociale
vous le savez être financés par nos
cotisations elle fait l'objet évidemment
d'allocations nous parlons aujourd'hui
les aides sociales financées par le
budget de l'état
je parle évidemment de la ss du rsa des
apl de la prime d'activité et tout cela
va faire l'objet d'une entrave à des
groupes de travail démarre une grande
concertation va être débuter une
consultation publique grand public a
débuté pour fondre ces aides sociales
dans un revenu universel d'activités de
façon à simplifier l'accès au droit pour
nos concitoyens c'est de cela dont nous
parlons aujourd'hui et pas évidemment
des autres allocations payées par nos
cotisations dans le cadre de la sécurité
sociale alors oui nous assumons
aujourd'hui quelqu'un qui est au rsa et
qui ne se voient pas proposer un contrat
d'accompagnement dans l'insertion au
bout de six mois c'est le cas de une
personne sur deux est au rsa à une perte
de chance elle a une perte de chance
pour se réinsérer dans la vie elle a une
perte chance parce que c'est une trappe
à pauvreté que c'est un déclassement et
qu'il faut aider ces personnes c'est
tout l'enjeu de la stratégie de lutte
contre la pauvreté que nous avons
inscrit évidemment et qui a fait l'objet
d'un grand consensus
donc oui il est important aujourd'hui
que les bénéficiaires des allocations de
solidarité s'inscrit vers un retour dans
un retour vers l'emploi par l'insertion
c'est de cela dont nous parlons et ça
n'est pas évidemment des à l'ocde
ce n'est pas une vision punitive mais
bien une vision d'un accompagnement nous
savons que certains de nos concitoyens
ne sont pas en mesure de travailler cela
des défis seront évidemment d'un
accompagnement adapté cela peut être une
heure par semaine de réinsertion mais
nous savons et les grandes associations
de lutte contre la pauvreté le savent
c'est un bénéfice pour les bénéficiaires
de cette allocation que d'être
accompagner vers l'emploi et vers
l'insertion je vous remercie
merci
seconde ma chère collègue merci et bien
pour nous l'insertion ce n'est pas la
culpabilisation
il faut l'accompagnement social pas le
contrôle social
vous avez supprimé les emplois aidés
voilà par exemple un exemple de
d'accompagnement social dans l'emploi
vous avez également et votre groupe à
l'assemblée nationale rejeter sans même
aucun débat la proposition de loi
socialiste sur le revenu de base et
voilà qui aurait pu faire avancer le
débat pour des aides inconditionnels qui
permettent de aux gens en difficulté de
relever la tête
la parole est à m collègues colette
mélot pour le groupe les indépendants
vous avez la parole
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues sale
juif tu vas mourir voilà ce qu'il est
encore possible d'entendre de nos jours
un samedi après-midi au détour d'une rue
de paris si comme alain finkielkraut
on croise une délégation de gilet jaune
amalgame d'une ultra gauche ou d'une
droite fascisante et de l'islamisme
radicaliser ce que nous vivons dans les
rues de paris
nous le retrouvons deux manières
décuplée sur l'internet ou
l'antisémitisme côtoie le sexisme le
plus primaire dans la plus grande
impunité comme la sphère de la ligue du
lol là on l'a honteusement montrer les
lois existantes se révèle insuffisante
il faut réformer se donner les moyens
d'agir contre la reine
tout est prêt le rapport du 20 septembre
2018 sur la lutte contre l'antisémitisme
et le racisme sur internet contient des
propositions importantes que nous devons
adopter et appliquer au plus vite
obliger les plateformes à retirer dans
un délai de 24 heures
tout contenu manifestement illégal
fournir l'identité des auteurs x 100 le
montant des amendes pour les moteurs de
recherche et les réseaux sociaux qui
manquent à leurs obligations
standardiser les procédures de
signalement étendre les prérogatives du
csa à la lutte contre la cyber n
monsieur le ministre cela fait cinq mois
que ces propositions sont sur la table
il faut légiférer au plus vite
voisins allemands ont pris récemment des
mesures fortes comme la nomination de
chargé de mission contre l'antisémitisme
suivi en cela par la commission
européenne
car c'est bien l'europe tout entière qui
est menacée d'une déferlante antisémite
monsieur le ministre de votre côté quels
agendas proposez vous pour vous répondre
la parole est au secrétaire d'état
auprès du premier ministre porte parole
du gouvernement
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice veut d'abord m'associer à vos
propos pour dénoncer l'ignominie qui
s'est déroulée dans les rues de paris
vous l'avez dit à l'endroit d'un alain
finkielkraut samedi mais rappelait aussi
que de nombreux actes antisémites
avaient été observés dans les rues de
paris et ailleurs à l'occasion de
certaines des manifestations que vous
avez mentionné
je commençais ma réponse en rappelant
que les réseaux sociaux sont aussi un
espace de liberté de découverte
d'apprentissage et qu'ils font tomber
les murs parfois bien réel pour beaucoup
de nos concitoyens et qu'ils sont aussi
cet horizon de liberté pour autant force
est de constater que chaque jour un peu
plus
ils sont devenus un exutoire un lieu
déversoir des haines qu'elle soit
raciste xénophobe antisémite homophobe
sexiste et que vous avez mentionné cet
exemple de la ligue du lol c'est bien
plus volontiers la ligue de la haine qui
s'exprimait dans le cadre de ce groupe
face à cette situation
marlène schiappa et mounir mahjoubi ont
proposé un plan pour lutter plus
efficacement contre le cyber-harcèlement
et le premier ministre l'a rappelé un
projet de loi sera déposé avant l'été
avec des axes de travail dont certains
sont communs à vos propositions que vous
évoquez dans votre question à savoir
améliorer la réactivité des plates
formes avec des systèmes de quarantaine
sur certains contenus très haineux avec
la question à ses centrales de savoir au
fond si les éditeurs et les hébergeurs
la distinction entre les deux et que les
plateformes qui héberge ses contenus ont
une part de responsabilité que le droit
actuel ne permet pas de porter à ses nus
sur cette question de la responsabilité
des contenus qui sont partagés
mais aussi se pose la question et vous
l'avez évoqué à demi-mot de l'anonymat
il n'est pas question de la supprimer
parce qu'après tout on peut vouloir
jouer un jeu vidéo en sur un réseau
social et garder l'anonymat
mais il est évidemment question de s'y
attaquer lorsque on a des propos
antisémites racistes ou sexistes qui
sont tenus c'est tous ces sujets là qui
seront abordés dans le cadre de ce
projet doit elle je suis certain que
cette assemblée comme celle de
l'assemblée nationale apporteront leurs
lumières à ces travaux importants
madame mélo quelques secondes
l'antisémitisme menace chaque jour
davantage de personnes vous l'avez dit
monsieur le ministre les discours
haineux
le harcèlement le sexisme se multiplient
sur les réseaux sociaux
nous attendons de manière urgente des
actes forts de la part de l'état pour
mettre hors d'état de nuire toute
personne qui fera l'apologie de la haine
sur internet comme sur le sol de notre
république
la parole est au président bruno
retailleau pour le groupe l'est
républicain
monsieur le président mes chers
collègues monsieur le premier ministre
il faut dire ce que l'on voit mais par
dessus tout il faut voir ce que l'on
voit ces mots de peggy alain
finkielkraut
on avait fait une exigence
intellectuelle il en avait fait en
quelque sorte sa devise mais de sfi
samedi ces mots ont une résonance
particulière
ce déferlement de haine ces mots ces
images virale insupportable que nous
avons tous vu mes chers collègues elle
nous oblige ces images elles nous
obligent précisément avoir avoir
justement que il y a bien sûr cette
montée inquiétante d'actes antisémites
dans notre pays
mais avoir aussi un surgissement le
surgissement d'un nouvel antisémitisme
qui comme l'ancien comme l'ancien s'en
prend à nos compatriotes au nom d'une
idéologie d'une idéologie qui n'est pas
celle des années 30 mais qui est tout
aussi dangereuse et curieusement et
curieusement ce nouvel antisémitisme a
trop longtemps été niée minimiser voire
même relativiser pour de fausses raisons
pour de mauvaises justification bien
souvent elles aussi idéologique
rappelons le mes chers collègues avec
fermeté un antisémite est un an cité
mythe qu'il soit fascistes ou frérot
salafistes
alors oui monsieur le premier ministre
bien sûr ce soir nous marcherons mais
marché ne suffit pas ne nous devons pas
marché les yeux bandés
oui à l'union sacrée mais non mais non à
une union qui écarterait la lucidité
monsieur le premier ministre il faut aux
efforts avoir le courage de dire qu'il
ya un lien de cause à effet entre ce cet
islamisme et l'antisémitisme
mais je ne crois pas nous ne croyons pas
que vous pourrez couper le lien
idéologique
justement avec ce lien civique sans le
mettre en cause je viens de finir ce
trajet lite et la laïcité
si vous changez la loi 1905 aux yeux de
premier ministre ma question pensez vous
que modifié la loi 1905 soit le bon
remède pour vous répondre la parole et à
monsieur le premier ministre
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le président retail beaucoup
d'aspects dans votre question d'une
dénonciation dans laquelle je me
retrouve bien évidemment d acte
antisémite de l'agression dont a été
victime alain finkielkraut
vous avez cité peggy on sait
l'attachement d'alain finkielkraut
ap eli lilly a dédié un livre le mes
contemporains nous avons assisté avec
consternation et peut-être même avec une
forme de colère et de rage au ventre à
cette mise en cause cru assumer brutale
d'un homme qui représente il n'est pas
le seul à le représenter mais la figure
de l'intellectuel engagé dans le débat
républicain vous n'acceptez pas assez
mises en cause
vous dénoncez l'antisémitisme moi aussi
c'est indispensable de le faire je le
disais tout à l'heure ça n'est pas
suffisant il faut dénoncer
il ne faut pas s'arrêter là il faut
avoir et et vous nous y avait invité la
lucidité de reconnaître que
l'antisémitisme est à bien des égards
profondément enracinée dans la société
française et dans l'histoire française
non pas que la france serait aussi
antisémite
il ya toujours eu dans les moments les
plus sombres des femmes et des hommes
parfois des institutions qui ont su
défendre ce que nous pensons de notre
pays ce que nous croyons de notre pays
mais il faut reconnaître que depuis bien
longtemps dans l'histoire de france
des formes d'antisémitisme parfois
varier coexistent certaines se développe
à certains instants et semble ensuite
s'adoucir si j'ose dire
alors que d'autres se développerait plus
vite vous avez évoqué le développement
d'un antisémitisme qui serait tissu
d'une radicalisation de l'islam qui
seraient issus des théories salafistes
qui parfois peuvent prévaloir dans
certains lieux et dans certains esprits
qu'il existe ce que je veux monsieur le
président retailleau c'est ne rien
cacher ne rien ignorer de ce phénomène
de l'antisémitisme en france il n'est
l'apanage l'antisémitisme d'aucune
formation politique et il a été à
différentes de l'histoire
malheureusement largement partagée
combattre l'antisémitisme
c'est un combat dont nous savons qu'il
est redoutablement difficile il faut
l'aborder avec détermination avec une
détermination je dirais presque sauvage
mais il faut aussi l'aborder avec la
lucidité de ceux qui savent que c'est un
combat qui dure depuis longtemps et qui
n'est pas fini un peu d'humilité face à
la difficulté
reconnaissons le ensemble peut permettre
peut permettre de ne pas et je parle
pour moi comme pour tous ceux qui sont
ambitieux dans ce domaine peut permettre
de ne pas nous payer simplement de mots
oui nous devons livrer ce combat en dix
ans ou l ennemi oui nous devrons livrer
ce combat en faisant le pari de
l'intelligence
il faut toujours faire ce pari de
l'éducation il faut toujours faire ce
pari de la formation
oui nous devons être plus sévère
juridiquement si j'ose dire compléter
nos dispositifs juridiques quand ils
doivent l'être incité autant que cela
est possible dans un pays qui promeut la
séparation des pouvoirs la justice à se
montrer sévère face à ses actes et de ce
point de vue monsieur le président je
n'ai aucune hésitation j'ai appelé à
l'union sacrée sans hypocrisie sans
exclusive sans incohérence vous avez
peut-être été frappée je l'ait été par
tous ceux qui après ces actes contre
alain finkielkraut contre alain
finkielkraut disait je les dénonce mais
est bas monsieur le président il n'ya
pas deux mais quand on combat
l'antisémitisme le combat point
totalement complètement c'est mon
intention
le premier ministre la parole est à
notre collègue éric goal pour le groupe
du rassemblement démocratique et social
européen
j'avais la parole et merci monsieur le
président mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à madame la ministre
chargée des transports
madame la ministre nous examinons cette
semaine en séance publique la
proposition de loi visant à faciliter le
désenclavement des territoires
vous le savez les transports sont parmi
les premiers facteurs de désenclavement
des territoires
si la proposition de loi s'intéresse
plus spécifiquement aux routiers à
l'aérien je souhaite vous interroger sur
un maillon essentiel de l'aménagement
des territoires
le transport ferroviaire dans son
dernier rapport la cour des comptes
conseillent à l'état d'abandonner son
rôle d'autorité organisatrice pour les
trains d'équilibré du territoire en
raison de la faiblesse de ses moyens et
des difficultés qu'il rencontre pour
établir une relation contractuelle
équilibrée avec la sncf
parmi les options envisagées figurent le
transfert total de la compétence aux
régions et le déconventionnement madame
la ministre vous l'avez vous même
rappelé l'investissement de l'état dans
le transport ferroviaire doit
aujourd'hui répondre à une exigence de
justice territoriale trente années de
financement des lignes à grande vitesse
ont mis en péril l'avenir des craintes
des trains d'équilibré du territoire
parmi ces lignes structurantes la ligne
paris clermont ferrand fait l'objet de
toutes les attentions en raison de son
caractère stratégique et de l'engagement
des élus des acteurs économiques et de
ses usagers le projet de loi
d'orientation des mobilités qui sera
examiné au sénat le mois prochain
provisionnent 760 millions d'euros pour
la régénération de son infrastructure
deuxième volet d'un vaste programme de
modernisation
si nous nous réjouissons bien sûr de
l'investissement de l'état sur cette
ligne nous interrogeons sur ses
intentions à plus long terme
d'une part en raison du récent rapport
de la cour des comptes d'autre part du
fait de l'absence dans la loi
d'orientation des mobilités dans
l'engagement sur le troisième volet de
ce programme de modernisation qui niait
qu'évoquer et encore moins financer
aussi madame la ministre
pouvez vous nous rappeler quelles sont
les mesures envisagées par le
gouvernement pour préserver
à plus long terme ces lignes
structurantes des trains d'équilibré du
territoire je remercie pour répandre la
parole et à madame la ministre aux
sports madame bornes à verre la ministre
avait la parole monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur eric gold je vais
être clair je considère que les trains
intercités répondent à un objectif
essentiel d'aménagement du territoire et
je sais que les français y sont très
attachés
alors oui ces lignes coûte de l'argent
mais nous l'assumons totalement la
politique d'aménagement du territoire ne
peut pas être traitée avec une approche
uniquement comptable
la proposition de la cour des comptes de
déconventionnement de ses liaisons
conduirait à une baisse significative
voire à l'arrêt de certaines dessertes
pourtant essentiel pour les territoires
concernés
ça n'est tout simplement pas
envisageable au contraire le
gouvernement s'est engagé dans une
modernisation sans précédent des trains
d'équilibré des territoires
ainsi pour la ligne paris clairement le
renouvellement des 28 rames et la
modernisation de l'infrastructure sont
inscrits dans la loi d'orientation dans
le projet de loi d'orientation des
mobilités sera débattue prochainement au
sénat
700 millions d'euros sont dédiés au
renouvellement des trains est par
ailleurs la réforme ferroviaire a permis
de sécuriser les investissements des
scènes cf réseau à hauteur de 3,6
milliards d'euros par an pendant dix ans
ainsi d'ici 2025
la ligne paris clermont sera équipée de
trains neufs et or a été remise à niveau
et modernisé vous le voyez monsieur le
sénateur le gouvernement est mobilisé et
engagé pour nos territoires notamment en
modernisant des lignes qui ont été trop
longtemps abandonnés par la politique du
tout tgv je vous remercie
merci la parole est maintenant à madame
à monsieur philippe bouyer pour le
groupe hli républicaine y avait la
parole monsieur le président madame la
ministre
le gouvernement a engagé de nombreuses
réformes dans le domaine du handicap
mais beaucoup d'inquiétude subsiste chez
les acteurs et des familles
six mois se sont écoulés depuis la
promulgation de la loi relative à la
liberté de choisir son avenir
professionnel dont l'ambition était
entre autres de garantir a pas cours
plus fluide aux personnes handicapées
six mois plus tard l'impact de la
profonde refonte de leurs th n'est pas
connu les directeurs des ath n'ont pas
caché la crainte que le respirer cette
réforme qui présente pour eux le risque
d'une diminution de leur carnet de
commandes
qu'en est il des constatations et des
décrets d'application relatifs à ce
texte
par ailleurs madame la ministre pour
qu'une personne handicapée puisse un
jour espérer intégrer le milieu
ordinaire du travail
ne pensez vous pas que la priorité doit
être d'aller ce tir dans sa formation
dès les premières années
malgré les efforts entrepris les
annonces contenues dans le projet de loi
pour une école de la confiance
le statut des avs et des msh n'est
toujours pas clarifiée qu'en est il de
la durée du contrat de travail du niveau
de rémunération des formations qui des
moeurs lacunaire et des différences de
traitement entre public et le privé
ne pensez vous pas qu'il est grand temps
de prendre des mesures urgentes en
faveur de l'école inclusive et de
l'accompagnement humain des élèves en
situation de handicap
j'attends votre épouse pour ma part en
état d'âme la secrétaire d'état en
charge des personnes handicapées valable
la ministre avait la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur mouillé merci de votre question
qui me permet de revenir
merci pour votre question qui me permet
de revenir sur deux chantiers
prioritaires du gouvernement
l'école et l'entreprise inclusive
l'emploi des travailleurs handicapés
d'abord le gouvernement redonne sa
pleine efficience à une obligation
d'emploi des travailleurs handicapés
vieille de 30 ans au travers de la loi
que vous avez cités que nous portons
avec muriel pénicaud la réforme agit sur
deux
levier plus de simplicité pour les
employeurs plus d'intérêt à s'engager
avec une incitation recentrer sur
l'emploi direccte comme toute réforme il
faut l'accompagner
nous avons longtemps puisque elle
entrera en vigueur le 1er juillet 2020
c'est le calendrier nécessaire à la
préparation des textes d'application
bien sûr mes outils des outils
nécessaires pour l'intégration et la
déclaration dans l'adsl et des nouveaux
services pour les employeurs et les
personnes les concertations sont
également engagés avec pour définir les
nouvelles modalités de valorisation de
la sous traitance auprès du travail du
secteur protégé et adapté
l'intention du gouvernement est très
claire c'est celle de continuer de
valoriser le recours aux esat et aux
entreprises adaptées qui joue un rôle
majeur dans les parcours d'emploi de 150
mille travailleurs handicapés avec une
méthode
le partenariat que nous avons entendu
renforcée au travers de l'engagement
conclu le 12 juillet dernier avec lui
est né à l'unapei et la pf france
handicap
il va permettre la création de 48
emplois dans les entreprises adaptées
d'ici à 2022 avec un soutien public
porté à 500 millions d'euros
voilà du concret du concret encore c'est
ce que nous apportons aux accompagnants
des élèves en situation de handicap que
nous avons pleinement associée à la
concertation que nous avons porté avec
jean michel blanquer ensemble sur
l'école inclusive la fin de la précarité
d'abord avec l'arrêt dès la prochaine
rentrée du recours aux contrats aidés
sur ces emplois enfin source de trop de
rupture pour les élèves et les
accompagnants
oui plus d'accompagnement monsieur le
sénateur et seulement d adressage
recrutés sur de vrais emplois publics
des emplois en dur d'une durée minimale
de trois ans renouvelable une fois
c'est le droit commun une vraie
formation ensuite des accompagnants
comme des enseignants comme prévu par
les dispositions du projet de loi pour
une école de la confiance que vous serez
bientôt amené à examiner
comme nous l'avions annoncé avec jean
michel blanquer la première lecture a
permis d'enrichir un chapitre complet
dédié au renforcement de l'école
inclusive
je sais compter sur votre compte sur
l'attraction pour continuer de
progresser je bouillais
madame liste merci pour votre réponse
technique mais j'aurais simplement vous
rappeler la méthode bien connue du
gouvernement en matière de concertation
car souvent les acteurs sont mis devant
le fait accompli au moment des
conclusions et donc la vigilance est
nécessaire notamment pour toutes les
associations qui sont concernés
concernant les abs et notamment
maintenant les ash nous sommes dans une
période où au cours du grand débat on
parle beaucoup de pouvoir d'achat et de
fins de mois difficiles
soyons vigilants notamment sur les
aspects de précarité car beaucoup de ses
employés aujourd'hui vivent avec moins
de 700 euros par mois sont confits le
devenir de nos enfants en situation de
handicap il faut responsabiliser et
donné la reconnaissance pour ces
professionnels
merci merci collègue christine lagarde
dont le groupe l'est républicain vous
avez la parole matière collègues
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre sous le quinquennat
précédent le pouvoir d'achat des
familles s'est considérablement héros d
abaissement du plafond du quotient
familial suppression de l'universite
alité des allocations familiales
abaissement des seuils de ressources
pour bénéficier de la page et réduction
de son montant le résultat ne s'est pas
fait attendre
le taux de natalité a baissé pour la
quatrième année consécutive la garde de
l'enfant de 0 à 3 ans est une source de
préoccupation le président de la
république annoncé récemment la création
de nombreuses places de crèche
si je loue la volonté je suis très
réservé sur les conditions d'application
les municipalités toucherait une
subvention annuelle de 2000 euros par
place de crèche créée à la condition que
les revenus des familles accueillies ne
dépasse pas 25 mille euros avec un
enfant 30000 euros avec deux enfants
le taux global d'accueil des enfants de
moins de 3 ans est le plus faible dans
les zones où le marché de l'immobilier
est tendu dans ces territoires
avec 2500 euros par mois pour élever
deux enfants et payer un loyer
vous êtes loin d'être riche dit
autrement votre gouvernement propose aux
mairies de créer des crèches réservé aux
familles pauvres
faisant fi de toute mixité sociale et
laissons de côté les familles modestes
quant aux objectifs fixés par la
nouvelle coche ils sont floues et laisse
les élus inquiets la paix est sud
n'augmentent pas ou si peu entre 2019 et
cette politique va empêcher la création
de places de crèche pire elle risque
d'en supprimer le reste à charge pour
les communes ne cessant de s'accroître
monsieur le ministre quand la france
aura-t-elle un gouvernement qui prendra
à bras le corps la politique familiale
pour la défendre et pour l'unifier merci
vous répondre la parole et tout
secrétaire d'état auprès de la ministre
des solidarités de la santé merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice christine lagarde vous êtes
bien placé pour le savoir en tant que
quatre jantes aux finances de la
municipalité de boulogne billancourt
l'accès des places en crèche et de la
compétence des villes nous avons mis en
place depuis le début du mandat de
nombreuses mesures favorisant la mixité
sociale dans les modes d'accueil du
jeune enfant et permettez-moi de revenir
sur un certain nombre de ces
dispositions que nous assumons le bouc
bonus mixité sociale tout d'abord il est
venu ce territoire du plan pauvreté qui
encourage les gestionnaires et les
villes à accueillir des enfants
défavorisés en compensant leur manque de
recettes
la réforme du complément de mode de
garde ensuite par la mise en place
effective du tiers payant et la
suppression de la condition d'activité
pour des bénéficier de ce complément
mode de garde
et pour rendre ainsi l'accueil
individuel auquel j'imagine que vous
êtes attaché aussi accessible que les
crèches
mais l'attribution des places de crèche
doit également être plus transparentes
c'est sur ce point que je souhaiterais
insister aujourd'hui devant vous et je
remercie à cette occasion
elisabeth laithier en charge du dossier
petite enfance au sein de l'association
les maires de france et adjointe au
maire de nancy qui a travaillé remis un
rapport à la ministre
agnès buzyn et à marlène schiappa à ce
sujet en présence de françois baroin que
vous le vouliez ou non la situation
actuelle est insuffisante et
insatisfaisante par dont l'insuffisance
de l'offre d'accueil la sur
représentation des enfants issus des
ménages les plus aisés dans les modes
d'accueil collectif alimente un
sentiment d'injustice sociale
en effet vous le savez seuls 5 % des
enfants de moins de 3 ans appartenant
20% des ménages les plus pauvres sont
accueillis en crèche contre 22 pour cent
des enfants des parents les plus aisés
la mission laitiers propose de mettre en
place une grille de critères
d'attribution sélectionnant des critères
pertinents parmi un large socle existant
en fonction des spécificités de chaque
territoire
ce vade-mecum décrit les différents
systèmes utilisés tels que la
priorisation la bonification ou encore
la pondération ses grilles pour être
adapté pour un contenu du suivi
c'est cette transparence et cette
diversité dans l'offre d'accueil qui
nous permettra d'assurer une meilleure
coordination des acteurs et je vous
rejoins sur ce point une meilleure
harmonisation des pratiques entre les
territoires
je remercie madame laborde oui monsieur
le ministre il me semble que vous n'avez
pas bien compris le sens de ma question
je voulais juste vous faire remarquer
que cette politique ne va faire
qu'accroître le français entre ceux qui
financent la presse les prestations
sociales et n'en bénéficient pas et ceux
qui les touchent
et comme vous êtes aussi un élu des
hauts-de-seine je vais vous inviter à
venir avec moi rencontrer les élus pour
percevoir les effets de cette politique
n'a pas sonné comme claude milito de
ville pour le groupe socialiste et
républicain lorrain la parole
ainsi notre président à ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'éducation nationale et de la jeunesse
monsieur le ministre alors que l'examen
de la loi pour une école de la confiance
vient de s'achever à l'assemblée
nationale je souhaite vous interpeller
sur la situation des 32 écoles
supérieures du professorat et de
l'éducation qui forme aux métiers du
professorat de l'éducation et de la
formation
ces établissements sont également des
composantes spécifiques intégrés aux
universités que nous avions créé pour
permettre la formation indispensable des
enseignants après la suppression brutale
et injuste et injustifiée des iufm par
nicolas sarkozy aujourd'hui les espèces
sont inquiètes
le pg elle vise en effet à les
transformer en institut ce qui suscite
des interrogations sur l'attention de ce
glissement de terminologie cette
modification pourrait porter atteinte à
la lisibilité de la formation des
enseignants et des cpe les sp ont sans
nul doute fait leurs preuves et sont une
des composantes reconnu des universités
elles craignent ainsi une perte de
notoriété d'autres passaient
transformation des écoles en institut
apparaît purement symbolique mais un
symbole dont le coût est estimé à un
million d'euros
alors que nos concitoyens sont
sollicités pour adopter des
comportements vertueux pour réaliser de
substantielles économies
ne serait-il pas emporté en l'occurrence
d'appliquer la même règle à tous les
niveaux de l'état
enfin la concierge
a sion semble avoir été absente dans
l'élaboration de cette réforme les
personnels expriment leur attente
d'informations d'autant plus que la mise
en oeuvre est prévue à la rentrée de
septembre
il est évidemment indispensable
d'associer les enseignants aux
évolutions car eux aussi savent ce qui
fonctionne ou pas alors que le mot débat
fleuri sur toutes les lèvres
n'aurait-il pas été opportun de
l'organiser en amont avec tous les
acteurs du monde éducatif
la ministre de l'enseignement supérieur
de la recherche et de l'innovation
vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
président mesdames les sénatrices
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice tocqueville la formation des
enseignants se déroule effectivement au
sein des universités mais je crois que
nous pouvons constater ensemble qu'elle
est encore perfectible et ce sur de
nombreux sujets notamment sur la place
du concours
et ça fait partie des sujets que nous
avons envers j'étais hier encore avec la
présidente du réseau des sp avec mon
collègue jean michel blanquer
et avec la conférence des présidents
d'université et croyez moi nous avons
largement travailler dans la
concertation de façon à faire de ces
futurs instituts au lieu de les appeler
écoles et bien des lieux où on est
capable de concilier à la fois la
formation disciplinaire d'excellentes
qu'elle était mais aussi une meilleure
compréhension de ce qu'est la réalité du
métier d'enseignant avec plus de
pratique professionnelle prévue dans les
programmes que nous allons mettre en
discussion dès la rentrée 2010 9
et puis aussi la façon de rattacher
mieux les pratiques professionnelles à
la recherche est donc évidemment ces
instituts ont toute leur place au sein
des universités
le dialogue se poursuit depuis
maintenant plusieurs mois avec les
responsables des sp avec les enseignants
chercheurs nous avons demain matin
union avec l'ensemble des organisations
syndicales pour évoquer cette réforme
il est évidemment indispensable que pour
préparer cette nouvelle
professionnalisation et que pour
préparer notamment une entrée accompagné
dans le temps dans le métier avec des
processus de pré recrutement nous
puissions être opérationnel à la rentrée
2010 9 pour ces pré recrutement de façon
à ce que nous ayons deux ans pour
construire le contenu des programmes
adaptés
la forme des concours au contenu de ces
programmes et faire en sorte que ces
jeunes qui seront en pré
professionnalisation dès la rentrée 2010
9 puissent ensuite rejoindre ses ex
d'instituts et former au mieux nos
enfants chômeurs si je remercie madame
la ministre mais vous dites vous même
que vous continuez à travailler à
réfléchir ce qui n'est pas rassurant
pour la rentrée 2010 9 et je note que
vous n'avez pas répondu à la première
question que j'ai posée
je remercie la parole est maintenant
président philippe cazaubon les
sénateurs mais figurant sur la liste
d'aucun groupe vous avez la parole
je vous remercie monsieur le président
monsieur mine mais chez le premier
ministre n'est pas là mesdames messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adressait à monsieur le
premier ministre lors de sa rencontre
dans le finistère il avait évoqué ses
convictions personnelles concernant la
mise en place de contreparties aux aides
sociales
j'avoue que j'ai été extrêmement
intéressé par sa démarche car il s'agit
d'un véritable projet de société qui
dépasse les clivages politiques
habituels
ça peut être un projet tout à fait
explosive s'il est mal compris ou mal
construits il ne s'agit pas d'être
punitif ou stigmatisants mais
incitatives pour être réintégré le monde
du travail et rendre à la société le
juste retour d'une solidarité nécessaire
ma question est donc simple à monsieur
le premier ministre kan en fera t-il un
projet gouvernemental at-il un
calendrier
et à quelle mesure at il déjà pensé pour
vous répondre la parole est à genève la
ministre des solidarités de la santé
faut dire que le premier ministre a
envoyé un mot il avait un impératif subi
qui l'a obligé à nous quitter
donc je voulais le dire madame la
ministre
merci monsieur le président monsieur
mesdames et messieurs c'est un terme sur
le sénateur adnot je le disais tout à
l'heure nous nous engageons dans un
vaste projet de refonte des aides
sociales en raison aujourd'hui de leur
complexité et du fait qu'il y a un fort
taux de non recours et l'incompréhension
de nos concitoyens face à ces multitudes
dead
donc nous avons prévu d'aller vers un
revenu universel d'activité celui ci va
faire l'objet d'une vaste consultation
en ligne qui s'ouvrira à partir du mois
de mars
et c'est dans ce cadre là comme dans le
cadre du grand débat national qu'est
posée la question éventuel une
contrepartie aux aides sociales mais je
le rappelle la question qui est posée
est celle des droits et devoirs et elle
est d'ores et déjà consubstantielle au
rsa tel qu'il existe aujourd'hui ce
principe de droit et devoir d'un
d'ailleurs jamais été remis en question
et tout le monde s'accorde sur le fait
que les droits et devoirs font partie du
parcours d'insertion des personnes
le problème nous ne savons c'est
qu'aujourd'hui plus de 50% des personnes
qui sont au rsa ne se voient offrir
aucun contrat de retour vers l'emploi
six mois après leur entrée au rsa ils
n'ont pas d'accompagnement appropriées
toute notre politique
tout l'enjeu de cette réforme et
notamment tout l'enjeu de la stratégie
de lutte contre la pauvreté
c'est bien de renforcer le parcours
d'insertion vers l'emploi et donc nous
allons travailler à une orientation plus
rapide vers des offres de formation et
d'insertion vers des offres plus
adaptées vers un renforcement de par
hasard
pardon de l'insertion par l'activité
économique et l'idée
est évidemment d'éviter ces trappes à
pauvreté tels que nous les connaissons
aujourd'hui
avec ce contrat le bénéficiaire devra
s'engager à suivre des formations
accomplir certaines démarches ou à faire
certaines activités pour favoriser la
réinsertion dans le cadre des
entreprises d'insertion vers l'emploi
voilà l'idée elle sera soumise à une
consultation au grand public
elle fait aussi l'objet du grand débat
c'est une des questions qui est
aujourd'hui posée à nos concitoyens je
vous remercie monsieur nô oui madame la
ministre votre réponse ne montre qu'il
restera encore pas mal de travail à
faire car vous répondez
comme si l'état était le seul
responsable en la matière je vous
rappellerai que les départements finance
le rsa que dans le département de l'aube
trois cent mille habitants
dix mille personnes qui relèvent du rsa
budget 40 millions par le département et
donc j'aurais aimé que dans votre
réponse vous disiez que vous alliez
associer les départements payeur au
travail pour faire en sorte que la
solidarité puisse effectivement donné
lieu à contrepartie intéressante je vais
vous donner un exemple nous avons dans
nos maisons de retraite des gens qui
sont submergés par le travail on ne peut
pas augmenter le nombre de personnes
parce que le prix de journée exploserait
j'ai dix mille personnes qui pourraient
être disponibles pour venir aider
accompagner faire des promenades et des
affaires manger à passer un peu de temps
faire en sorte que la société soit plus
compréhensive et je pense que ça aurait
mérité et ça mérite qu'on ait un autre
échange que celui là c'était un peu
court
merci
nos prochaines questions d'actualité
auront lieu le 7 mars et je vais lever
la séance avec un ordre du jour qui
reprendra mercredi demain de 14h30 à
18h30
la séance est levée
[Musique]
thual it et du sénat au gouvernement des
questions marquée par la montée de
l'antisémitisme en france avec notamment
une intervention du président du groupe
l'est républicain au sénat
bruno retailleau qui a pointé la montée
d'un nouvel antisémitisme un
antisémitisme issu de l'islam radical et
notamment du salafisme
un constat qui a été partagé par le
premier ministre edouard philippe qui
lui a répondu et qui a appelé la justice
à être plus sévère sur toutes les
affaires antisémite une sévérité tout en
respectant la séparation des pouvoirs
et puis autre constat cette fois-ci
pointé par la sénatrice centriste
catherine morin desailly qui est
président de la commission de la culture
au sénat et qui dénoncent l'explosion de
cette haine antijuive sur les réseaux
sociaux
edouard philippe a assuré que sur ce
sujet il y aurait bien une loi proposée
par le gouvernement
une loi qui va rendre responsables les
plateformes de réseaux sociaux qui
héberge ses contenus et des contenus qui
dont les auteurs se cachent souvent
derrière l'anonymat
donc voilà jérôme pour les temps forts
de ces questions d'actualité du sénat au
gouvernement alors que les sénateurs et
de nombreux membres du gouvernement vont
maintenant se rendre place de la
république à paris pour le rassemblement
contre l'antisémitisme
merci beaucoup alexandre pour ce résumé
des questions d'actualité au
gouvernement est justement va rejoindre
un des membres du gouvernement en la
matière agnès buzyn la ministre des
solidarités qui est aux côtés de tam
traduit en salle des conférences
oui à la nièce busin edouard philippe
l'a dit tout à l'heure dans l'hémicycle
le combat il est redoutablement
difficile dans la lutte contre
l'antisémitisme
cet antisémitisme il est multiforme
aujourd'hui eh bien c'est la profanation
du cimetière juif de quatzenheim dans le
bas-rhin 96 tombes profanées votre
réaction à cet événement
oui encore encore un événement abject on
en a vu beaucoup depuis quinze jours
mais depuis plusieurs semaines voire
plusieurs mois puisqu'on a noté en un an
et une augmentation de 74% des actes
antisémites dans notre pays
nous savons que cet antisémitisme il est
d'extrême droite et d'extrême gauche
il est parfois aussi d'origine islamiste
radical jean luc mélenchon a dit
attention il ya de l'instrumentalisation
politicienne de tout cela qu'est ce que
vous lui répondez pas écouté il suffit
d'entendre deux voies qui aujourd'hui
s'exprime dans les manifestations des
gilet jaune avec des propos antisémites
je crois qu'il ne faut pas nier
l'évidence ion commence chacun à dire ça
n'est pas moi c'est l'autre
je crois que nous n'arriverons pas à
régler le problème il faut qu'on regarde
en face et qu'on ne se voile pas la face
justement sur qui au sein de chaque rang
au sein de chaque parti politique
aujourd'hui en france laisse filer et
admet en son sein des personnes qui ont
des propos ouvertement antisémite ou
parfois masqués d'ailleurs ça n'est pas
toujours d'une franchise extrêmes
certains laisse planer des ambiguïtés
notamment quand ça commence par je suis
contre l'antisémitisme mais c'est ce
qu'a dit le premier ministre tout à
l'heure à partir du moment où on met un
mais c'est que déjà le combat est perdu
agnès buzyn tout à l'heure le président
de la république a dit il faut punir on
prendra des lois c'est très difficile de
lutter contre l'antisémitisme il ya tout
un arsenal juridique déjà présents que
faut-il faire en plus pour vous au
niveau notamment juridiques
d'abord il faut l'appliquer appliquer la
loi telle qu'elle existe sans agir pour
vous aujourd'hui pas suffisamment en
tous les cas il faut l'appliquer à
chaque fois ne rien laisser passer
c'est difficile parfois puisque quand il
ya une multiplication des actes ça
nécessite une vigilance de chacun donc
il faut que la loi soit appliquée et il
faudra peut-être renforcer l'arsenal
notamment sur les réseaux sociaux car
ils vont tuer l'absolument ans et sur
les réseaux sociaux aujourd'hui que
cette haine antisémite s'exprime le plus
facilement en toute impunité
et c'est là où probablement nous avons
des progrès à faire vous êtes favorable
à la levée de l'anonymat sur les réseaux
sociaux
je n'ai pas suffisamment travaillé le
sujet mais sur certains points quand il
y à des propos haineux je suis favorable
il faut permettre aussi l'anonymat dans
certaines conditions nous le savons sur
les jeux vidéo par exemple
certains disent qu'il est important de
pouvoir garder un anonymat voilà je
crois qu'il faut qu'on soit attentif à
ce que cette levée d'anonymat
soit réservé aux propos extrêmement
haineux que nous retrouvons sur internet
mais la stib aubagnaise besoin d'avoir
répondu à mes questions et nous allons
continuer et bien à vous poser des
questions sur cette lutte contre
l'antisémitisme à ce sujet qui était
vraiment fondamentale au sein de cette
séance de questions d'actualité au
gouvernement avec jacques bigot bonjour
bonjour sénateur du bas-rhin d'abord à
bien votre réaction à la profanation du
cimetière juif en alsace time avec 96
tombes ont été profanées
alors j'ai une pensée pour la communauté
israélite bas rhinoise qui est très
importante et le kit une fois plus
frappée il ya quelques mois c'était à
herrlisheim
non c'est insupportable c'est
insupportable et ça se redéveloppe alors
on en a eu d'autres 1 mais là ça devient
extrêmement grave
je pense que il faut effectivement qu'on
puisse arrêter les auteurs de ces faits
c'est compliqué je sais qu'on va
demander sans doute qu'ils aient des
systèmes de vidéosurveillance etc mais
ça va être très compliquée à mettre en
oeuvre mais c'est vrai qu'on a un
sentiment d'un antisémitisme voire d'une
forme de nazisme qui remonte puisque
c'étaient des croix gammées qui était
sur ces tombes profanées néonazisme donc
au cimetière de herrlisheim la dernière
fois c'était même un monument à la
mémoire des victimes de la shoah qui a
été ainsi tagué
donc on sent bien effectivement qui est
un antisémitisme et il ya quelque part
aussi un fonds de nazisme qui revient
comment est-ce que vous l'expliquer ce
retour de l'antisémitisme déjà depuis
plusieurs années on parle d'augmentation
des actes antisémites
je crois qu'il ya toujours eu une forme
de rejet
il ya toujours une recherche dans les
difficultés d'un bouc émissaire
et puis je pense aussi que nous devons
travailler très sérieusement sur le
dialogue interreligieux jeu qui se fait
d'ailleurs en alsace la possibilité de
comprendre tout en respectant la laïcité
qui est à la fois le droit de croire ou
de ne pas croire mais aussi le respect
et la tolérance à l'égard des
convictions qui pour vous de nouvelles
lois ce matin le président de la
république a dit on va prendre des lois
on va en faire de nouvelles alors je
pense qu'il a seul dans l'émotion et
n'inclut il a dit surtout qu'il faut
poursuivre sanctionnés je pense que s'il
y a besoin de nouvelles voies il fera
réfléchir je crois pas aujourd'hui qu'on
ait besoin d'air le premier ministre à
l'heure aux questions d'actualité a été
plus nuancé en évoquant la question des
réseaux sociaux de ce qui peut se faire
par internet et qui peut pousser au
propagande antisémite bien merci à
beaucoup jacques bigot d'avoir répondu à
mes questions mais merci tam pour ses
réactions évidemment liée aux actes
antisémites et aux mobilisations qui ont
lieu un peu partout ce soir en france
pour les dénoncer
la séance de questions d'actualité que
vous avez pu suivre en direct et en
intégralité a évidemment été marquée par
ce thème est le premier ministre edouard
philippe a répondu
aux sénateurs sur les moyens à mettre en
oeuvre contre cet antisémitisme
il faudra que nous changions le droit
national et il faudra que nous obtenions
de nos partenaires européens que nous
complétions le droit communautaire
ça vaut la peine je crois profondément
madame la sénatrice que nous devons
légiférer en la matière car il ne serait
pas acceptable qu'en matière
d'antisémitisme nous donnions le
sentiment que l'impunité pourrait
prévaloir c'est vrai aussi s'agissant de
la sévérité des sanctions qui sont
prises administrative lorsque c'est le
cas judiciaire lorsque c'est le cas
j'incite je ne peux pas dire le terme a
cité par dow je souhaite que
systématiquement les affaires dans ce
titre sémitisme donne lieu à des
poursuites je souhaite que
systématiquement elle donne lieu à des
sanctions sévères
nous devons en la matière mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs et je le dis je
le dis ah je le sais des femmes et des
hommes qui en sont convaincus nous
devons en la matière faire l'union
sacrée sans exclusive sans hypocrisie
sans incohérence l'union sacrée pour
dénoncer ces faits inacceptables et nous
retournons voir thème traduit en salle
des conférences tam vous êtes avec
philippe mouillé sénateurs les lieux les
républicains des deux sèvres
oui philippe mouillé edouard philippe
tout à l'heure a déclaré il faut faire
l'union sacrée pour lutter contre
l'antisémitisme
votre réaction eh bien à tous ces
événements du week-end et cette
profanation d'un cimetière juif ce matin
alors je crois qu'on ne peut être que
d'accord avec la proposition d'edouard
philippe tous se mobiliser pour cette
cause qui est essentielle mais au delà
d'union sacrée c'est aussi la capacité
de pouvoir réellement réagir et apporter
des solutions des propositions pour
lutter contre l'antisémitisme et là nous
avons des interrogations que nous
portons auprès du gouvernement donc
mobiliser en faveur d'un objectif commun
mais quels moyens quelle solution est
aujourd'hui proposée par le gouvernement
on attend encore des réponses elles sont
vos interrogations pour vous il faut des
lois supplémentaires que faut-il faire
tout à leur honneur intérieure a
également parlé bien de la question de
l'islamisme
alors oui d'abord choix qu'il faut
savoir nommer un donc qui sont gérées
les aujourd'hui les sources qui portent
ces messages extrêmement négatif et puis
en même temps d'abord appliquée et
multiforme on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui
on a dans tous les
les extrêmes donc c'est des relents
d'antisémitisme qui sont aujourd'hui
horrible et je crois aussi il faut
d'abord au delà de nouvelle loi déjà
appliquée faire appliquer les textes qui
sont en vigueur et avec de la fermeté et
de la réactivité
voilà et à partir de là nous sommes
capables aussi de faire adapter
rapidement nos textes pour les plus loin
il ya le débat des plateformes
numériques c'est évoquer très largement
lors des questions d'actualité
aujourd'hui il faut aller beaucoup plus
loin et savoir réagir pour pouvoir
clairement être des acteurs pour
combattre ce fléau
un mot philippe millet bien du thème que
vous avez développé lors de cette séance
de questions d'actualité au gouvernement
pour vous le gouvernement est il à la
hauteur dans la question de la lutte
pour le handicap et pour qu' il y ait
une société plus inclusive aussi bien au
niveau de l'école que dans l'entreprise
alors le gouvernement a enclenché de
nombreux chantiers intéressant dans
lesquelles nous allions nous sommes
engagés à ses côtés mais de beaucoup
nombreuses questions restent aujourd'hui
en suspens et notamment ses premiers tic
d'incapacité mobiliser tous les acteurs
les associations les structures dans ce
changement on peut pas simplement
décrétée gérer une nouvelle orientation
il faut aussi mobiliser et avoir une
véritable concertation
c'est le sujet de l'emploi des personnes
handicapées
c'est le sujet de l'école inclusive qui
va être très tôt les jours qui viennent
aujourd'hui on souhaite également des
réponses concrètes et bien merci
beaucoup philippe moullier d'avoir
répondu à mes questions et merci thème
traduit c'est la fin de cette édition
merci à vous de l'avoir suivi dans 30
minutes vous retrouvez rebecca fitoussi
pour une émission spéciale dont va plus
loin
largement consacré au rassemblement
contre l'antisémitisme excellente suite
des programmes sur public sénat
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]